У Німеччині буде створено фонд з метою захисту "Північного потоку-2" від санкцій США.
Це рішення уряду федеральної землі Мекленбург–Передня Померанія 7 січня затвердив місцевий ландтаг.
Фактично йдеться про створення буферної компанії. Що цьому передувало?
Будівництво газогону "Північний потік-2" було замороженим з грудня 2019 року.
Адже з проєкту вийшла швейцарська компанія, яка надавала судно-трубоукладальник для будівельних робіт.
Швейцарцям загрожували американські санкції. Причому з нового року вони стали ще суворішими -
через припис у новому оборонному бюджеті США.
Будівництво газової магістралі у грудні поновили. Однак проклали лише невеликий відрізок
довжиною два кілометри шістсот метрів у економічній зоні Німеччини.
А санкції спрямовані перш за все на те, аби завадити добудувати відрізок на великій глибині -
він був розташований у територіальних водах Данії. Причому США погрожують драконівськими штрафними заходами і партнерам проєкту.
Офіційний Берлін різко критикував політику Вашингтона і продовжує підтримувати будівництво магістралі,
в яке було вкладено орієнтовно 11 мільярдів євро. Однак ніяких контрзаходів німецька влада не планує.
Натомість у ситуацію втрутилася регіональна влада, дуже зацікавлена в проєкті.
У землі Мекленбург-Передня Померанія магістраль переходить з моря на сушу.
Тож уряд цієї землі вирішив створити спеціальний фонд захисту клімату й довкілля,
який у разі необхідності має захистити учасників проєкту від санкцій США.
Федеральний уряд Німеччини опинився перед дилемою, коли він має
врахувати інтереси усіх зацікавлених сторін. І він не може виправити допущену помилку,
пов'язану із підтримкою цього проєкту. Тиск дуже великий. І земельна влада вирішила, що діяти треба їм.
Я розумію, чому федеральний уряд поводиться в цій ситуації стримано. Адже тепер це
куди більше, ніж приватний комерційний або енергетичний проєкт.
Фактично фонд повинен зіграти роль буферної компанії - посередника,
який має відвести удар від "Північного потоку-2". Однак формально - це держфонд для захисту клімату,
і тому в Мекленбургу-Передній Померанії сподіваються, що влада США не наважиться завдати удару по структурі,
безпосередньо пов'язаній з німецькою владою, нехай і регіональною.
Прем'єрміністерка цієї землі Мануела Швезіґ відзначила, що підтримка будівництва є лише одним з можливих завдань фонду, але не єдиним.
Головне завдання фонду - захист клімату й довкілля. Я впевнена, що з допомогою цього фонду
в нас буде можливість у найближчі роки реалізувати багато гарних проєктів. Це потрібно нашій землі.
За повідомленнями ЗМІ, земельний уряд збирається вкласти у фонд 200 тисяч євро.
Щоправда, на тлі внеску Nordstream2 у розмірі 20 мільйонів євро це, звичайно, радше символічна сума.
До речі, влада невипадково обрала захист клімату підставою для підтримки магістралі.
Адже ФРН збирається відмовитися від використання атомної енергії та вугілля,
а частка відновлюваних джерел зростає не так швидко, як хотілося б.
У цій ситуації роль так званого перехідного ресурсу відводиться саме газу.
Наш план полягає не в тому, щоб цей фонд будував або був оператором трубопроводу.
Ідеться лише про те, аби надати фонду можливість зробити внесок у завершення будівництва магістралі.
Чи буде ця опція необхідною і чи використають її, залежить від того, чи будуть США робити ставку на санкції
проти європейських і німецьких компаній. І тому важливо, аби уряд ФРН зробив усе
для того, щоб ці санкції були скасовані.
Цей план розкритикували представники природоохоронних організацій.
На їхню думку, створення такого фонду -
це підміна понять і ляпас захисникам довкілля.